well next I would like to present our
silver medal winner I would like to but
I will not because there is no silver
medal medal winner and it took me about
an hour to figure this out today a rich
have to explain to me but there was a
tie for first place so there is no
silver male there are two gold medal
winners and a rare rare occurrence here
so congratulations this hardly ever
happens so it's it's like a comet
Kohoutek or something so I first first
we will look at one of the winners and
the first one was made up in San
Francisco at the Academy of Art
University by a Bernardo Worman and chef
woojong okay first of all first of all
electing the Academy for this
opportunity it's a great honor to be
here tonight and like wow like thank you
for giving us like the gold medal
exactly and they look at me first thank
you like congratulations to you and most
important fall tonight Lisa Alan could
you please stand up please Allah is the
third director of dragon boy good come
to stage Lisa Lisa you belong here we
first come here Jonathan
Ryan Katelyn Josh JD Liu aye
Andria and the bank you guys are
fantastic thanks for being a part of
this awesome I'd like to thank our
teachers and mentors who guide us to
this process
and I can only speak for me at this
point and above all thank you to my
parents my brother and my lovely wife I
love him oh thank you so much thanks
Wow I guess I'd like to congratulate all
the winners tonight I I just get blown
away every time I see the talent in all
of the work here so uh yeah and a huge
thanks to the entire crew that worked
tirelessly to see the project through as
well as the Academy of Art University of
course Lisa and Bernie thank you for
standing me throughout the whole project
he's from a family beautiful girlfriend
Brandi who has survived me through all
of this and big thank you to the Academy
for the great honor and the
unforgettable week that we've had
you've been warm you've been welcoming
and you've made us feel like a part of
the family of storytellers and thank you
what they said oh I didn't prepare
anything so unfortunately we couldn't
like to submit to names for our project
and I I watched the coin toss but
seriously but it was wonderful meeting
all the other nominees such a talented
group of beautiful people and thank you
so much to the Academy and our school
and and just everyone it's been a
wonderful week thank you